hi everyone I'm Joe Albahari over from
in Australia I'm the author of c-sharp
in a nutshell and if does anyone here
use link pad I hope that's good good
show of hands is actually and Norway is
the second highest per capita user of
link pad in the world it's one of your
neighbors is their highest per capita so
I want to ask who remembers doing this
as a as a kid long multiplication is
something our parents or teachers taught
us to do and they programmed us to do
this in the same way that we program
computers right so they pretty much fed
us an algorithm you multiply this number
by this number and you put this digit
here and you add these things up
together right that's a an algorithm and
if we were to program a computer to do
this and that's not such a silly
question because the first computer I
ever had I programmed in machine code
and there was no there was it was no
multiplication so I ended up doing
something kind of like this to multiply
numbers and you're pretty much going
through the same kind of algorithm you
would go through the way we were taught
to do this but we take it for granted
that when we learn to do this we already
knew how to recognize that that was a
for right and how did how is it that we
knew that we our parents didn't program
us like a computer with an algorithm to
do this we learn through example just by
seeing lots of these digits we figured
it out right now if you want to get a
computer to recognize handwritten digits
and you would have come up with an
algorithm that's really difficult to do
right so why can't we get the computer
to learn in the same way and learn by
example and that's exactly what machine
learning is right with machine learning
we have lots of input and output and it
works out the algorithm gradually ters
from looking at lots of samples and a
particular kind of machine learning
algorithm is own artificial neural
network as with well West with nearly
all machine learning architectures you
can kind of look at it like this there's
an
algorithm there whose behavior depends
on a whole series of internal constants
these are really just floating point
numbers and then as we train it by
feeding in lots of samples it works out
the optimum values of all of those
constants it's effectively how it works
so a machine a an artificial neural
network they're arranged like this so
here's an example on the Left these
these white circles these represent the
inputs and they might correspond to all
of the pixels in an image so you might
have values from 0 to 255 to represent
the level of gray the grayscale then
that connects to another layer of
neurons which in connects to another
layer which is where we get the output
from will go into this architecture in
more detail later but the important
thing for now is that those internal
constants are represented by the
sensitivity of the neurons we call that
the bias of the neurons and the strength
of the interconnections between the
neurons we call the weights and if we
represent those by colors this is what
the training looks like we start out by
initializing those weights and biases to
small random values and that's why they
look great at the moment because we're
going to think that the color is going
to represent the the weights of biases
then we feed one of these numbers into
this like a for now because it's
untrained it's gonna get that wrong you
might think it's 7 so then we ask the
question what adjustments do we need to
make sure those weights and biases to
make it a little bit less wrong we just
make some really small adjustments to it
then we do the same with another sample
and then we put a good 50,000 samples
through that and that's called an epoch
when we're finished we shuffle those up
into a different order and repeat it
again and after several epochs gradually
that the weights and biases start to
take shape it starts to settle down into
a set of values that lets us correctly
infer the characters that's essentially
a nutshell how it works
so if you want to do this most people
we'll go out and use a library because
there are numerous libraries to do this
and these libraries are the product of
years of R&D and they do things you
can't easily do yourself like make use
of the graphics processing units in your
computer problem is when you start using
these that they're very powerful but
they're all black boxes it doesn't
really help you understand how they work
it's not particularly interesting you
guys in it's all hidden away and it's
rather like in if you've ever played
with a flight simulator and you start
out with something like that and it's
it's really cool you follow the
instructions and hopefully if you've got
all the configuration correct you can
take the thing off and fly it you get
one little thing wrong and it crashes or
doesn't get off the ground and it's not
very satisfying you don't know what
you're doing and you come back a week
later you've forgotten everything
all right because you never really
understood what was going on it's much
better after a while you go back to this
you start to learn how to fly that and
you really get to understand the
principles of flying and when you come
back to this everything makes a lot more
sense it's a lot more fun in this
session we're not just going to fly this
we're going to build it from scratch
right so starting from the lowest unit
which is in Euron so a neuron has one or
more inputs it needs usually stew to be
useful and all these inputs and weights
everything these all real numbers has
one or more inputs and it also has a
bias so when we fly the neuron we apply
some numbers to those to the inputs and
we multiply them by the weights and add
up the bias that gives us a total input
simp simple linear arithmetic then we
put it through a nonlinear activation
function and we get the output
that's essentially what a neuron is now
the simplest kind of neuron is called a
perceptron which uses for the activation
function a comparator it asks a very
simple question is the total input
greater than zero if so it outputs a 1
otherwise it outputs a zero so let's
give an example we're going to create a
neuron and we're going to initialize the
bias to 3 and each of the input weights
to minus 2 and I'm going to put some
numbers in and to make it real simple
we're just going to put binary numbers
but of course we could put anything in
here we can put
large small positive negative
floating-point numbers so let's go
through the mass with this so we
multiply each of those inputs by the
weights and then we add in the bias so
that gives us a total input of 1 now 1
is greater than 0 therefore we output a
1 now if we just swap those two numbers
around we're going to get the same
result because these two weights are the
same right so we could 0 1 or 1 or 0
we're going to get the same result as
before let's put two zeros in there
right now when we do the maths the total
input is 3 which is still greater than 1
so we output a 1 and let's now put two
ones in there the total input is now a
minus 1 right that's less than 0 so we
output a 0 so what we've done here is we
have created a NAND gate a logic gate
now with an and gate Asst you can build
any other kind of logic gate from the
NAND gate by combining them together so
we can do anything with this this is
infinitely powerful however we have kind
of cheated because we pre-programmed the
weights and biases remember what makes
us interesting is this can learn this
can figure out the weights and biases
through example so let's play that out
and see what happens
we're going to now initialize these now
to small random numbers these are
actually quite large for but for the
example this will work fine so I've
initialized them now and now we're going
to put a couple of numbers in 0 & 1 and
we're going to play that through and
we're going to get an output of 0 in the
end because the combined inputs minus
point for that's less than 0 so the
output 0 the correct answer is a 1 so
we've got this wrong so what we ask is
what small adjustments do we need to
make to the weights and biases to make
this a bit less wrong problem is with
the way we've done it here is if we make
a any small change we make to the
weights or biases we're going to get
exactly the same answer because we're
either right or wrong there's no nothing
in between there's no gray scale this is
not conducive to learning right
either off or on it so if we look at
that comparative function and we plot it
it's like that right if we want to make
it conducive to learning we need to make
it more like that so now this is kind of
intermediate area this gray area so if
we don't get it right we can see the
direction we need to go into in order to
get to where we want to go this is
called a logistic sigmoid and this is a
popular function without official neural
networks but the problem with it is if
you look at the formula for that
function that's quite expensive to
compute now sometimes we're going to be
using 50,000 samples there are some
neural networks that we're working with
Millions
right and and with many over many epochs
that's very wasteful so over the years
people have experimented with other
functions and what they found is that
there's something that works really well
that's really cheap to calculate it's
more complicated to pronounce than it is
to calculate and it's called a rail
you--or rectified linear unit and it
simply x equals y if X is positive or 0
if X is negative variation on that which
works in most cases slightly better is a
leaky le where FX is negative we divide
it by a hundred that gives us a little
bit of a slope on that side right so if
we if we now plug in a leaky aurelio or
a logistic sigmoid into our our neuron
we can now train it the only thing we
have to be careful of now is in the end
of the day we still need to interpret
the answer as a 1 or a 0 because we're
trying to write a NAND gate and so it's
pretty simple to convert this this
continuous output into a discrete output
we just say we want a 0 or a 1
what's it closer to so if it outputs a
point 2 that's closer to a zero we'd say
we'll treat that as a zero anything
greater than point five we'll treat that
as a one alright but what we've gained
is the ability to measure the error if
it gets it wrong we know how long it is
and what direction it needs to go to be
more to be less wrong so in this case
let's suppose the desired output is zero
the actual output is point two we can
say the error is zero point two
we define the error as the actual output
minus the desired output nots the error
can be positive or negative now it would
seem reasonable that we our goal is to
minimize the total error across all
training samples right problem is that
won't actually work very well at all
right and to see why and go through an
example we imagine across this is one
training sample imagine our other three
training samples we get exactly the same
output we get zero point two for all of
them and imagine that the correct answer
is zero for all of them so it got all of
them correct all of them we have an
error of point two right if the error is
less than point five we'll go back a
slide if the error is less than point
five we get it right
errors more than point five we get it
wrong so in this case four of them
errors point two and all of them have
got the more correct imagine another
scenario now the first three the error
is zero but the last one the error is
point six so now it's got one of them
wrong but look at the total error the
total error is lower in the second case
so if we program the machine to minimize
the total error across all training
samples it's going to favor that second
outcome over the first outcome right it
does exactly what we tell it so what we
need to do instead is we need some way
to punish the big errors more than the
small errors the easiest way to do that
and by far the cheapest is to is to
square the error first all right so if
we square all those errors before adding
them up the first case we get point one
six the second case we get point three
six so now it will favor the first case
so now we're no longer minimizing the
total error per minute we need another
term to describe what we're minimizing
and the term that we use is called the
loss right or the cost that's a synonym
right the loss is whatever we're trying
to minimize we can define that loss
function however we like but the most
popular loss function is the error
squared
simple and easy to calculate right a few
nuances rather than defining losses to
some of the error squared we usually
define it as half the sum of the error
square that makes no difference
if whether you minimize X or you
minimize half of X you can end up in the
same place the difference is it creates
a nice mathematical simplicity and
symmetry that we'll get to later another
nuance is we could also instead of
calculating that the the total the sum
of the error squared we could calculate
the mean of the error squared again
exactly the same result you'll sometimes
see the term MSE mean squared error
that's exactly the same thing another
interesting thing is that we don't
usually calculate the loss right how
many of you here drive that's a lot of
hands I guess because the taxis are so
expensive here right all right now most
of you will probably consider yourselves
good drivers and yet if I were to ask
you what is the probability you're going
to have an accident on the way here
you're not going to be able to give me a
number right and yet you could be
constantly doing things every day to
monitor your your safety and improving
your safety you could you could be it
you can minimize something and improve
it without actually measuring it right
so in the same way if you look for the
code that measures the loss in this you
won't necessarily find it because we
don't actually need to calculate it in
order to minimize it so let's get back
to our example and we'll plug a leak
here Lu in now to our neuron so we're
gonna little eyes it again small random
values for the weights and biases I'm
gonna put a 1 in a 0 in there the
combined inputs now 0.3 now we plug it
into that leaky earlier now what should
the output be if the inputs 0.3 you can
plug it through a leak here Lu what
would the output be yeah that's it point
three it's greater than zero anything
greater than zero we just take the x
equals y so it's seven point three now
the correct answer of course is one
right one and zero is one so the actual
output is point three we can now
quantify the error as minus
0.7 so we can see now that what we need
to do is increase the output how do we
know because we always want to go in the
opposite direction of the error right so
we want less of the arrow not more of it
right so we slip the sign we want to
increase this and maybe if we couldn't
make this point 301 that would be a good
thing right
it's just a wine back a step we want to
adjust these weights and biases right to
make this a bit less wrong but what we
need to know first how do we adjust them
to do that we start from the right when
we work backwards work from right to
left so we start with this and we say
well the error is negative that means we
need to increase this slightly so be
good if we could make this point 301 we
can't control this but we can control we
can work backwards so we can say what do
we need to do to this to this combined
input over here and because we're on the
positive side of the relia when the x
equals y it's exactly the same thing so
if we increase the output that means we
also need to increase the input if we're
on the leaky side of the rally right
then we will be dividing by a hundred
right so it would be it would be a bit
different so we need to increase the
output so remember this is for one
training sample we've got three others
and then we're going to go over them
again and again and again right so we've
got to take into account the wishes of
the other training samples as well so
one way in which we could do this is we
could repeat this exercise for the other
three training samples and take votes
saying who wants to increase the bias
who wants to decrease this weight and
then whichever gets the most votes wins
and then we make an adjustment and
continue but problem with doing that is
we would be minimizing the total error
not the total loss if everyone gets one
vote then it doesn't matter whether you
really need to make an adjustment or not
right you're all getting the same say
and so we need to be a bit smarter in
how we do it so what we do instead is we
give a variable number of votes to each
training instance and that vote is
simply the negative error so this one
gets zero point seven votes because it's
out by points
'even if it was owned if the error was
minus 0.1 it would only get 0.1 votes so
that way we take much bigger action when
there's a bigger necessity right when
this when this are a bigger error right
so if the output gets point 7 votes the
input gets point 7 on the positive side
of the rally if it was on the negative
side of the rally the input would get
zero point
0:07 votes who would divide by a hundred
that would mean that would that our we
would be doing almost nothing right
we've been making almost no changes
which is what we want right it's very
when you're training these things you
want to be very careful because if you
make anything at any change you make can
break it for other training samples so
if it's not going to make any difference
for you you don't to break it for anyone
else okay so the input gets point seven
votes now we need to make we could now
go to all the other training samples and
collect up the votes but we don't need
to there's an easier way to do it right
if we were to do that it's called
batched learning where we collate it for
all of the samples but they say there's
a more popular and more efficient way
called stochastic learning where what we
do is we make a small adjustment after
every training sample and move on and
the end result is similar to what we get
if we added them all together and made
one adjustment so in this case the step
size is called the learning rate at
learning rate of point oh one multiply
that by the input votes of point seven
the adjustments point double-oh-seven so
now what we do is we take that bias of
point one that now becomes put 107 we
add it to that and we also add it to
this weight here which becomes a now
point 207 the second weight however you
notice I've not made any adjustment to
that at all why not why have not
adjusted that that weight
luckily it doesn't change the output and
why doesn't it change the output because
this is zero it gets multiplied by zero
remember we don't make adjustments
unless is actually going to help us
because all will do is mug it up for the
other training samples so we've done
that training sample we've made and some
changes to the to the weights and biases
we just keep repeating that for all of
the training samples over and over and
that's all there is to training a neuron
we've covered the whole algorithm for
stochastic gradient descent all right so
before we code it up though I'm going to
go in a bit more detail on a couple of
things right just for the sake of
mathematical curiosity one is to explain
how it is that were actually minimizing
the square of the error even though we
didn't calculate it and the other thing
is to explain why it is how we deal with
this rally why is it that we multiplied
by what is effectively the slope of this
function right we were multiplying right
well the output got 0.7 votes the input
got point seven we multiplied by the
slope of this function wherever it is
now and explained that let's switch to a
logistic sigmoid right if we used that
activation function the black line shows
you what the function looks like and
this gray line shows you the slope at
any point so when it's right in this
point we're switching off and on it's
got the steepest slope so it's going to
get the most activity so the input the
output any changes in the output will
affect the input significantly but on
either side of it's over here or it's
over here it's kind of switching off
it's not the and it changes in the
output are not going to make much
changes to the input so explain how this
works imagine you're a politician and
you'll try to decide on a policy for
whether Norway joins the EU because
apparently there's a vacancy coming up
soon so you go from constituency to
constituency visiting all your
electorates gauging the public opinion
on their gap gathering votes
but you're not going to treat all
electorates equally right there's some
people out on the streets demonstrating
you know you are you he other words no
II you know are you and you go to
another electorate and then don't care
one way or the other right the strength
of the sentiment it's very important so
that will be equivalent to the output
votes is the strength of the sentiment
as a politician you're in Iran your
learning is you go from electorate to
electorate each time you go you adjust
based on the on the output votes so do
do politicians have have an activation
function right today do they what what
you doing here when you're multiplying
by the slope of dysfunction you're
applying the chain rule in calculus
right if you didn't understand the chain
rule before you you know it now so do
politicians do this do they apply the
chain rule when that when they're trying
to decide policy they most certainly do
right politicians focus their efforts
into where they get makes the most
difference right where that slope is a
steepest right that's where they make
that what that that's where it has the
greatest say so often they'll decide
policies maybe this is in Australia I'm
sure it's not like this in Norway but
often they'll decide policies to please
the marginal lecturers
right even at the expense of upsetting
some save seats or unwinnable seats
right because that that's how they can
win the election so that's pretty much
how it works in terms of the
deactivation function now in terms of
how is it that we're calculating that
the square that the loss the minimizing
that the loss rather than the error I've
plotted here a graph showing you the
error in green and on the the x-axis is
the input so when the input was 0.3 the
error was minus 0.7 and you can see that
if we shift the input to the right
that's going to improve the error now
let's plot the loss function on here
remember loss is half of error squared
that's what it looks like now it just so
happens very nice coincidence that every
point on that graph the slope of the
loss function is exactly the error
right because when you differentiate
half white cause half x squared to get y
equals x so what we're doing is with
when we take a step to the right in
proportion to the error we're taking a
step in proportion to the slope of the
loss function so you imagine that you're
sitting that's a slide you're sitting on
that on that slide you're going to go
down at a speed proportional to its
slope right and eventually you'll go
down further and further and then you'll
slow down as you get close to the bottom
cuz a lot of steep and you'll settle
down where that loss is a minimum so
you're doing a gradient descent on the
loss even though we haven't actually
calculated it that's what we're doing so
because we're doing stochastic gradient
descent we only do we only make one step
before changing over to a different
curve right different sample different
training datum once we repeat the same
thing we might now go the errand our
might be 0.35 so we now take a step to
the left it's only half as much now
because the slopes only half as much as
we had before okay so that the end
result that we get is the same as if we
were doing a gradient descent on the
combined loss function for all of the
samples together so that's the mass
behind it then without any without too
many symbols
so to summarize for each training sample
we determine the slope of the loss
function at the current position right
remember this is really easy in practice
because the loss function is simply the
error it's minus the error right and we
step by the following amount the slope
times our learning rate and that's it so
I think it's time to code something up
and we're going to do this in link pad 6
which is I've just I've released the
first preview a few days ago this runs
on dotnet call three so on preview six
so even but there might be it might be a
little bit unstable so bear with me I've
got link pants five here in case it all
crashes and burns so we could go to that
we'll see how it goes so first thing
we're gonna train this NAND gate I'm
gonna have a look at the clock of critic
classes for this hope is actually pretty
good for for writing this in in terms of
creating code that's fairly easy to
follow
so I've hard coded two weights onions
gonna have to do weights it's gonna have
a bias and I initialize the weights and
biases to small random numbers now when
you're doing low P because part of the
feature of our PS as contrast to
functional programming is we have state
and we mutate it right and we do that
proudly because it's good for
performance reasons in this case but
when you're doing it you want some
hygiene over your states so it's very
good to separate long term state from
short-term or transient state by putting
them in separate classes it's good
practice I mean in this case the the
long term state is the weights and
biases right this changes very slowly as
we trained it and then what we've
trained it they're kind of become
constants we can save them to a file and
load them back up again and they don't
change while we're actually using it for
inference the transient state is that
they're all these temporary things like
the total input right that's a that's a
transient that's a transient state so
I've created another class called firing
neuron which captures that all the
transient State for inferring for firing
and for learning so to fire we multiply
input one by the weight of the first
neuron add together input 2 by the 2nd
weights add up the bias that's all there
is to it all right then we apply the rel
you so if the input is this is the
activation function is greater than 0
it's a total input if it otherwise it's
the total input divided by a hundred if
it's negative now the here's a here's
the more interesting but here's how it
learns so it so they're given two inputs
and an expected output and the learning
rate how we do it it's the first thing
we need to find a neuron so that we know
what the output is the second thing is
to work out the output votes
remember all it is it's the negative of
the error right the error is the output
minus the expected output so the output
votes we just flip it the other way
around right that's equivalent to taking
two deriving the loss function right the
slope of the loss function then we apply
the chain rule so we multiply it by the
slow
of the rally right so if the total input
is greater than zero we multiply it by
one otherwise we multiply it by 0.01 and
now for the input votes we multiply that
slope of the rel u by the output votes
right so that this is well we're
applying the the margin electorate test
right so if it's if the slow if you
output is greater than zero it's like a
marginal extra otherwise it's safe C to
unwinnable C so now we can work out the
adjustment is the input votes times the
learning rate that's that small figure
and we add that to the bias and we also
add it to each of the weights but we
remember we always multiply by the
inputs so if the input zero it's not
having any effects so we don't want to
make any adjustments and if the input is
negative we want to adjust it the
opposite direction so that's it that's
all the code there is to it so all of
this stuff you can download this so if
you go to link pet go to samples there's
a link here called download import more
samples you click on that link and then
scroll to the bottom and then it will
they'll be at they'll be a sample you
can click on to download this so we're
gonna most of the result of the Cote is
just creating test at data and testing
it so to manufacture data it's very easy
we can we don't have to download the
data we can make it up we just create
whole lot of random pairs of zeros and
ones and then we know what the desired
output is by applying the NAND function
so let's just dump the sample data first
out to see what it's like and we'll run
that so you can see what the sample data
is so here we go got lots of random
inputs and we know what that's the NAND
as a desired output okay so that's how
we start out the next thing we need to
do is we need to separate it into
training and test out it because it's no
good if we use all our data to train it
because then we won't know how well it
performs in the real world because it
might be that it works really well with
the data that we've trained it with but
when we give it data it's never seen
before it screws up so we didn't we need
to know that it can generalize to stuff
it hasn't seen so we take usually 20% of
the data we lock it away that's our test
data and the
the data is our training data were going
to use 80% for training so basically
we're splitting up to the training and
test data we're training it now we're
calling the learn method on each of
these and then we doing a report on how
accurate it was so let's run this now
and see it and see what the result we
get it's pretty quick this tells us
after 200 right we're trained it was 200
let's go up to the top
total samples we fed a thousand samples
we unit a learning rate of 102 and it
got of all the 200 which remember we
took 20% away for the for the test data
of all of those that got them correct
these are the final weights and biases
bias 1.17 and the weights were negative
points or something so that worked
pretty well now because we use small
random weights and biases each time you
run it it's gonna be slightly different
right but each time we run it it always
gets it correct we can have a bit of fun
with it save what we reduce the total
samples to a hundred what happens then
does that work it doesn't in this case
it's got six correct so it's got 14
correct and 6 6 wrong so not enough we
need more than at more than a hundred
samples we can also try increasing the
learning rate 2.5 see what happens then
the learning rates too high again this
screwed up because the learning rate is
too high it will oscillate so you
imagine you're on that slide and you're
going down you have too much momentum
you're going to go up to the other side
again you need to keep oscillating so
that learning rates too high we can also
try seeing we can change the function on
here and see can we teach it to do NORs
we change it to an all in sort of an and
we can train it to to be inaugurated and
again that works perfectly the nor gate
what about if we can train it to be an
XOR gate let's try that it's failed it's
got hundred and roughly the same number
right and wrong train that again it
can't do a nor gate so what I saw an XOR
gate we can't train it to do an XOR gate
why not
right that what to do an xor gate it
needs more than one neuron right we need
to feed the output of this neuron to the
input of another neuron right to do an
XOR which which leads us to the next
part of the session because I did
promise you a Cessna but so far were
kind of got a hang glider right so we're
going to go back to the back to the
presentation
just so that we can see what the here we
are so this is this is this is now a a
network of neurons so what we do when we
connect them together it's a pretty
simple architecture so all our inputs on
the Left they're not neurons at all
they're just inputs they just hold a
number each of these holds that the
pixel value in one of these in this case
and then we organize them into layers on
the right hand side is the output layer
so we have one of these per possible
answer so in this case I've got ten
digits we'll have ten output neurons so
whichever one gives us the highest
number that's the one it thinks it is
right and everything in the middle are
called hidden neurons or hidden layers
and we organize them into layers so the
input for this neuron here every input
every neuron in the hidden layer gets
its inputs from every pixel every of the
input layer and similarly on the app on
this next layer here on the output layer
every one of these neurons derives its
input from the outputs of these neurons
here so it's a pretty simple
configuration now to fire it we go from
left to right right it's called
feed-forward when we're firing it so we
start by firing all of the hidden the
first layer of hidden neurons and this
can be done in parallel right it's very
conducive to parallelization so then
we'll end up firing all of these now
once we've done that we can now fire the
next layer across so we can fire all the
output neurons and now if we do that we
should get ho little numbers if we feed
one of them in there and in this case
the number eight is the highest so it
thinks it's an eight if there was
another one there that had say point
four it wouldn't really matter too much
right
so just as before big errors are much
worse and smaller or small errors don't
matter right as long as it the highest
one is the one at which it's supposed to
be that we've done pretty well so we're
going to use the same loss function for
character recognition we're going to use
the the square of the error as a loss
function so when it comes to training
this again it's pretty much the same as
what we're doing before but now we work
backwards we work from right to left so
we start by training all of these output
neurons and exactly what we did before
the same process we did find the same
loss function we know what the desired
output is we know what the actual output
is we trained each of them in exactly
the same way and now we need to move to
the next layer over here in this case
we've got one hidden layer and there's
one piece of the puzzle we need which is
how do we work out what the output votes
is for each of these hidden neurons
right because we don't have an expected
output anymore there's no desired output
and it's the simplest possible thing
that can work you take all of the
neurons that it connects to here all of
their input votes and you do a weighted
sum rights the weighted sum of all of
these interconnections that's all it is
anything that was simpler than that will
be leaving out something we didn't waste
it that would be a bit weird and if we
ignore some of the neurons that be a bit
weird so it splits a simplest possible
thing that can work so what can I go
ahead now and I've coded all that up and
I'll show you what looks like now the
neurons got a bit more complicated the
only extra complexity there there's a
lot more code in here but it's all
plumbing it's just wiring things
together there's very little in terms of
neuron logic in here but I'll show you
which bits are different we've now got
an array of input weights instead of
just having two and what the bias I've
also created a pluggable activation
function so instead of hard-coding
the rail you I've created an abstract
class called activator and you can
subclass it so I've got all the popular
activation functions are there for you
to play with this is like a playground
from your network so with all white
boxes and there are no libraries in here
absolutely no
library's no conflict files for us all
here so I'll show you now also what the
that's our neural network which contains
layers of neurons
that's our firing neuron now and again
compute function to compute the total
input same as similar to what we had
before we just we do a weighted sum this
is the method to adjust the weights and
biases this is part of learning
now one thing you can do in C sharp is
great in terms of you can really easily
paralyze something and we want this to
use all available course to do that all
you have to do is parallel dot for right
however there's that there's a
possibility of creating contention and a
hotspot because we have to update the
weights and biases we're updating shared
variables right these weights and biases
so we need to have a lock so we want to
minimize the time spent in that lock so
there's another nice feature of c-sharp
you can use pointers when you really
need this kind of performance advantage
this speeds it up about 30% by changing
from you know from using the arrays to
using pointers that's our firing net
that's our feed forward and we just go
from layer to layer firing all the
neurons
can we call compute outputs and here is
the one thing when it comes to the
learning this is the one extra bit of
logic that's related to the neurons
rather than to the plumbing so for the
hidden neurons we need to work out the
how many output votes to give it we take
the weighted sum of the next layer to
the writes input slopes right all the
input votes and this is where we're
doing it we're using the sum of all of
the next layers input votes times the
input weights so that's pretty much it
so that's that's the logic in terms of
the there's few more minor things I made
little adjustments to the learning rate
for each layer I found that improve stir
that the rate at which it it learns so
we need some training data now
fortunately there's a public domain a
really good public domain data set
called EMA nest this code automatically
downloads it for you if you don't
already have know we downloaded it and
it's nicely divided to 50,000 training
images and 10,000 testing images right
so this creates the neural net
this is the number of input inputs it
has then uncle neurons the number of
inputs because of their square images
it's the image width height squared this
is the number of neurons in the first
hidden layer xx and because we've only
got one hidden layer for now this is the
number of neurons in the output layer 10
so this is pretty dumb it's only got 30
brain cells in total but we'll see how
well we can do with 30 brain cells we're
going to trade it with a learning rate
of point o 1 and 10 epochs we're going
to go over the whole thing 10 times and
let's run it in the removable report ok
so the first epoch we've got a training
accuracy of 93% it's got to 95 in the
second epoch up to 96% now this is
pretty good for 30 brain cells right now
a final after the 10 epochs our final
training accuracy is 96.5% but what
really matters is the test accuracy
because remember how well can it
generalize to stuff it hasn't seen yet
right and it's actually done pretty well
it's still 95.6%
accurate now this shows us the failures
at the highest loss this is the things
that had the most trouble with right and
you can see that's a problem note that
it supposed to be right that's but that
was supposed to be a 2 that was supposed
to be a 6 I thought it was a 5 that was
supposed to be a 3 well no no what was
that you're supposed to be a 3 so on so
now one of the things you can do in in
link pad is you can like visualize this
so you can enough written to visualize
that which for this so what I call this
what it will do is it will show us all
the states of the the weights and biases
as it's running so when you dump this
out you can actually watch it learning
now so you can see it's starting to take
shape now the color right now this is
only show this is not showing you the
inputs it's showing you the hidden
layers because there's too many inputs
to show you it's showing you the hidden
layers and it's showing you the output
now on the right hand side we've got a
canvas that we can draw on because it's
one thing to run it against the test
data but it's something else to actually
you know draw something on here so wish
me luck I'm gonna draw something and see
how I connect how it goes
so put a 1 in there it got that right
which is kind of surprising he's gonna
either go I like to almost a 7 all right
got that right so that's a for all the 4
it's not doing terribly well as in now
there's a problem here it's that this is
something or interesting because it's
getting about 40 30 percent accuracy how
did it do so well with with the training
data and things so poorly and you don't
have to look for configuration files or
you've used the library wrong so your
code it's all there right so there's got
to be something you've done wrong um and
this is really when you learn when
you're under this kind of problem this
is really when you learn how this stuff
works
and when you look carefully at the
samples what you can see is that they're
all been really nicely centered that was
part of the scanning processes that they
scented them so this is being completely
confused by the fact it's not perfectly
centered right so there's no danger of
this taking over our jobs so there's two
ways we can solve this one of them is
what we can do what's called data
augmentation we take all those samples
and we shift them and we rotate them and
put them up and down left and right and
then next we get it to teach it how to
deal with that like this one way there's
another way which is easier in this case
is which we can simply Center this
sample before feeding into the neural
network which is what I've done here so
I've already done I just need to
uncomment the code so I'm gonna take
this off and run it again ah a CH
exception external component this is a
bug in dotnet call three preview six I'm
not blaming it on link pad you just have
a quick look at that look away I'm gonna
see what satisfactory
ssam there are you that's in the wind
formstack alright okay so let's have a
look now again and see how well this
works so it's done it's done that any
box and it's got it right let's try
something a bit harder it's got that
right I haven't even finished the five
it's got it right this is doing pretty
well now just with that century now one
interesting thing is if I draw I may
draw seven I'm gonna really carefully
like a typewriter and do it really
nicely it can't get that because people
don't write like that it's never seen
anything like that before
that's completely confused it right so
it's this is interesting how it works
because obviously we could train it with
that kind of stuff so we can actually
improve it though because we've got a
final training score of 96 percent and
there's a number of ways we can improve
it one is we can create more layers so
in there somewhere I'm gonna put Creek
increase up to 30 but I'm gonna add
another hidden layers two layers in
there now I'm gonna train that forget
about that exception yeah we can see see
that extra layer in there now
this is using all the cause so it's
getting the fans starting up now on
their on the on the laptop it's quite a
bit faster if you put a new hex core or
a m8 call machine in there runs quite a
bit faster now you see this is going up
the the training schools going up or up
to 98% now when you get more than than
what two layers we're now doing deep
learning right that's way cooler than
shallow learning okay we've got a final
test accuracy of ninety six point eight
we've gone up a little bit but to be
honest you could with this particular
kind of problem you can get the best
result just by by increasing the number
of Naraku layers rather than three and
just increasing the number of neurons in
that in that middle layer just having
one hidden layer but something else we
can do because I told you we had our
pluggable activation functions what we
can do is I can uncreate a new
activation function in here so I'm to
change the activation function on that
middle hidden layer to a an exotic one
softmax activator with cross-entropy
loss right now that sounds really fancy
and it is but it what this actually does
is not it's not just changing the
activation function it also changes the
loss function it gives us a more
elaborate one we're going to train that
see how that goes and what's doing that
I'll cover a couple of other things
which is this gradient descent that we
talked about before that's that that's
nice curve applies to a single training
sample but when we take all of them into
account we end up with something way
more complex and you get this phenomenon
called local minima where you get you
know it can end up getting stuck in
there and this is one of the reasons why
we initialize the weights and biases to
small round and valleys so just by re
running it over and over again you'll
end up in different spots so you choose
that you know which
gives you the best final result but one
way you can help avoid that problem is
if you keep it simpler so if you have
fewer layers for your complexity in your
function what you end up with is you
still get the local minima but they're
all quite close together right so it
turns into a less of a problem and what
we're doing here is pretty simple so we
don't get too many of these problems see
how this is doing now it's kind of slow
isn't it that's running so slowly I'm
going to do I'm gonna stop this I'll put
a woman just gonna reduce this to 15
Euron's that is a much slower activation
function this is one of the things you
have to at a trade-off you're making and
doesn't matter whether using this or
using a big library like tens of flow is
that sometimes it's better to use an
inferior activation function and loss
function if it's quicker because you can
get way more iterations done you'll end
up getting our better results sooner
anyway so sometimes it's not always
better to have the better function it's
training quicker now and what you find
with this is that with with this
activation function we can get right up
to 99% 99.5% training school on there
but the problem is when it comes to the
actual test score it's no better than
what we had before and this phenomenon
is called overfit
and what it means it's done a really
good job of fitting all of those
training samples but it can't generalize
the stuff it hasn't seen as well as
you'd like and that's overfit and that's
what's what happens tends to happen with
this exotic activation function and loss
function right well 99.4% accurate on
our training but the test accuracy is
only 97.8%
so we can actually get the best result
for the final test accuracy by going for
anything up to I'm going to stop at 200
but we can up to a thousand you've got a
thousand neurons in that middle layer
and then that will that will get you
about ninety eight point something
percent 98.5 percent accuracy which I'm
given the simplicity of this is is quite
quite good so while this is going
there's something else I'd is it still
going well as the SCH SCH exception
finally got the better of it it is going
okay so something else I want to do
which is how what do we do if we want to
get even better than that we want to
solve more difficult problems like you
know recognizing what kind of object
whether a so fluffy cat or a dog in the
picture and the way these more advanced
neural networks operate is unlike this
neural network which is a
general-purpose you can use this kind of
network to solve a whole variety of
different problems but what you can do
is we can desert we can make this so
that it's only designed for image
processing and nothing else and when you
do that you can end up with something
which works a lot better for image
processing for instance you could start
by running rather than reading feeding
the raw pixels into the neural network
you can first run it through some
filters and do things like edge
detection and line detection in circle
detection and then you feed the output
of those filters into the neural network
and that gives you quite a bit better
result now what's really clever about
that about that architecture is that you
don't have to figure out you know how to
design those filters all you have to
decide is how many filters you want
because when you write these filters the
way they work is you use matrices which
all it is is a bunch of numbers you can
describe a filter which does something
like edge detection just with a bunch of
numbers basically what you put into a
matrix now once you've got a bunch of
numbers in there you can allow the
neural network to figure out what value
is to put into those numbers through
back propagation exactly the same
mechanism we did before the back
propagation you can get it to tune the
field say decides on the filters you
only decide I want ten filters and and
initialize those filters to small random
values it will tune them
and that's called a convolutional neural
network and that's the basis of a lot of
the deep learning networks today that do
image recognition something else I'll
hold on to describe which is what to do
if you don't have much training data
because we've got 50,000 in this case
and sometimes you don't have that amount
and there is a court a technique called
pre-training you can do or transfer
learning and that is that that imagine
that we wanted to now train train it to
to to do letters well let's say we
wanted to train it to do numbers but we
didn't have any numbers of samples but
we've got lots of letters what you can
do is you can train it first reduce
letters to a similar kind of thing and
then once you've optimally trained it
you can save all those weights and
biases off to a file right so now it can
now do letters and now when you want to
train it to do numbers when you've only
got a small set of numbers what you can
do is rather than starting out with
random weights and biases you start out
with that pre trained network you got
that was capable of doing letters and
you find that it actually does a much
better job because there's similarities
between the letters and numbers so it's
kind of learned something in there
that's kind of encoded how to do some
recognition and it's now applying that
to a slightly different task so it's
called pre training or all transfer
learning probably pre trains a better
term for that and that that's that's
what's done it also extensively with the
the deep learning networks that you can
play with such as tensorflow
is if you want to do an image
recognition task you can download
something which is already being trained
with millions of images on the internet
let's go back to that and have a look
see how it's doing it's getting very hot
I'll tell you that so while that's going
any questions we've got five minutes
okay the different colors in the lines
is represents the on the on the neurons
the color represents the final bias of
those of the bias of that so that's
constantly changing so that's the bias
and the color of the it's power to tell
the so many of them but the color of
these lines is the waste represents the
weight so blue is negative and red is
positive any more questions
sad to see here with the lights
okay so we've got a final test accuracy
of a now 98.3% with and this is with two
hundred two hundred and Euron's on the
hidden layer and ten on the output layer
so we'll give it another go with
fat-fingered that one but that's worked
yes it's doing a pretty good job now so
this this is similar to what you'll get
even with some of the commercial ones
it's only slightly better than this so
yes of that I'll be I'll be hanging
around so if you want to talk to me
afterwards about this um you're welcome
to come and see me so thanks everyone
for you for coming
[Applause]